[Music]
we're on our way
[Music]
and that's why coffee's for grown-ups
[Music]
if you're impressed imagine how i feel
mom
[Music]
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia
was given their own magical gift
uh-huh uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect isabella
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with the nade
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
[Music]
let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
[Music]
a lot of stairs
but at least i'll have a friend nope you
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
you